una polémica más en el Twitter de elon
musk El controversial Magnate
sudafricano anunció a través de un tuit
que ha decidido limitar el número de
publicaciones diarias que pueden
visualizar los usuarios esta decisión se
debe a niveles extremos en la
recolección de datos personales por
agentes externos a la aplicación
las cuentas verificadas están limitadas
a leer seis mil publicaciones al día las
cuentas sin verificar a 600
publicaciones al día las nuevas cuentas
sin verificar a 300 publicaciones al día
esta controversial decisión Del
multimillonario se une a la larga lista
de turbulencias en la dirigencia de
Twitter como la entrada de la
suscripción de pago Twitter Blue las
constantes caídas de los servidores y el
recorte masivo de personal sin embargo
la disminución en La regulación de
contenidos dentro de la aplicación es la
medida que ha polarizado más al internet
y podría entrar en conflicto con
normativas de organismos como la Unión
Europea
discursos de odio los actos de
terrorismo y muchas otras cosas que
vemos en redes sociales ya no serán
posibles
el anuncio de elon musk provocó una
oleada de críticas por parte de los
usuarios de la app lo que obligó a la
actual ceo de Twitter a extender el
límite de visualización a casi el doble
de lo anunciado originalmente